[Music]  hey what's up guys I'm Kay Bhd here and  I'm here at CES 2013 of course and we're  here with one of the stars of the show  the 6.1 inch huawei ascend mate this is  one of Huawei's high-end smartphones but  it's surprisingly not the highest and  even though it sort of blurs the line  between phones and tablets it's got a  6.1 inch 720p display not 1080p sort of  somewhere in between the galaxy note 2  which is 5.5 inches and surprisingly the  iPad Mini so that's what we're looking  at right here  so yeah that's basically it this is the  huawei ascend mate they also have a  huawei ascend d2 which is a smaller  5-inch 1080p smartphone and that looks  like it's gonna be their flagship for a  year but I figured I'd show you guys  this super superduper phone which is a  one of my favorites this year so thanks  for watching and I'll talk to you guys  in the next one  [Music]